danny's in grand forks north dakota hi
danny how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
oh well uh so an interesting
opportunity's come up recently
uh where there's a potential where i
could be working in a six
figure job but it would require a move
um and me and my family are are very
well firmly planted in this area
we planted a church recently and i
worked two other jobs as well
um and so i guess i was curious what
your thoughts were on something like
that because that
from my from my standpoint in life uh
going up that much in a yearly income
through one job is very
i never dreamed it'd even be something
that could potentially be on the table
what's the job uh via project management
is it something you love to do that you
want to do
yeah i've been i'm good at management
you know it's something that i've done
uh for for eight years um but you know
my calling is to help and serve people
and speak life into people's lives
you know so i work full-time in the
fitness industry and then i pastor
part-time
and then i work with people with mental
disabilities part-time as well
do you have kids yes i have two kids and
a wife
so it sounds like you already know the
answer do you feel guilty about not
taking a six-figure job
yes sounds like you don't want the job
sounds like you don't want to move
yeah so you got permission to not take
the job man
thank you yeah i i agree with that
the other side of it is yeah seasonally
man is this a moment in your life when
man you could really bite the bullet for
four or five years and
work really hard in something i i don't
always buy the
my my let me put it this way i'm i'm
like you
i have a i feel like i'm good at helping
folks
i've done that behind closed doors at 2
a.m with
police departments i've done that with
college kids i've done that with college
kids
parents i've done that with adults at my
house
now i do it on the radio it's a
different assignment but the mission
stays the same so if you care and love
helping people
you can do that as a project manager you
can also do that
volunteer at a local church or with
people with disabilities right
you can do all those different things
and so dave i struggle with this
this calling i've gotta only do this
thing
i think you can do your life mission in
a number of different places a number of
different
uh a number of different roles and if it
gives you 5 10 15 25 hours a week back
to your kids and your wife
that's an invaluable thing right yeah i
i i give you permission to do either one
and i'll just
echo what john's saying what ran through
my mind is
is that um somehow you've gotten in your
head
that in order to be helping people you
have to be broke
no and i have to be i have to be doing
personal training and be a minister
part-time
because in business you can't be helping
people actually that could be the
biggest mission field
the biggest ministry that you've ever
had in your life managing projects and
leading young people
and uh i mean you could speak into their
lives in so many ways i do every day
with our person
with our thousand people on this team
here um
it is one of the biggest ministries that
i have
is the leadership role here at ramsey
not just on the radio
and so um you know the idea that you
know
you can you can be a restaurant owner
and be in ministry you can
uh so it's just it's a mindset of how
you get there i kind of think though you
don't want to leave grand forks
that's also in the mix that we drove
past pretty quick so
this is both a career and a location
thing
the only thing i would challenge you is
don't turn this down
because it's not holy and what you're
doing is holy
right that's all i'm saying that would
be a mistake
but if you don't want to do that thing
and you don't want to live in that city
and the only thing taking you there is
money you're going to be miserable don't
go do it
don't go do it because i mean money does
not solve everything dude i mean if you
eat enough lobster it tastes like soap
i mean you just get more money at some
point so
uh but but also you don't you know you
don't have to work for a non-profit to
be holy
uh you don't have to be small time to be
holy
your work can be holy when you decide it
is
and you have a other centered matrix
that you're looking at it through